what our group is really trying to do is
improve current state-of-the-art voice
recognition software so that's for
example siri that you would have on your
phone or any other sort of voice
recognition software
and so
currently the way things work is we have
hundreds of thousands of hours of
training data that we're able to use on
these machine learning algorithms and
based on that data we're able to say
that these waveforms are most likely
going to correspond to these phonemes
which are kind of the building blocks of
sound like the t or the s or the a sound
and so
we have all this data and we're able to
create a pretty good system to determine
speech
however
all other languages but english don't
have as much training did it's hard to
get hundreds of thousands of hours of
really robust clean training data so
what we're trying to do is
create a classifier that's going to be
able to work for smaller amounts of
training data so for example if we bring
a language classifier out to turkey and
are trying to train it on their language
it will be able to be efficient and
effective without hundreds of thousands
of hours
the way we plan to do that is by
actually analyzing the probabilities and
the the
basically the correspondence of
different phonemes in succession so is
it likely that this phoneme if heard
directly after this phoneme uh is going
is there a high chance of that or is
there a low chance of hearing this
phoneme after this phoneme
the way we're creating those results is
by really looking at languages across
the world and seeing how
what what the phoneme structure and kind
of the spread the probabilities of them
all look like and so we hope to use
those probabilities as an extra step to
update the current models that we have
in voice recognizers to see if those
improvements and those added
probabilities can actually make our
classifiers more accurate and so that's
kind of the overall view and with that
the end goal with this project is
hopefully to be able to create language
classifiers that work with less data but
are just as effective so we can bring
this sort of technology all across the
world